we should expect more and more erratic  weather events  as a result of climate change and it's  not just it gets really hot it's record  heat  and record cool  and maybe more hurricanes and storms  sub-hurricane storms as well storms that  don't quite get to being hurricane level  but are bad storms potentially snow  events etc  uh it's not looking particularly good is  it  no these weather events are going to  happen more often they're going to be  more and more severe we've known this  for a long time and maybe people will  start to wake up to it um there was talk  about how maybe republicans will be more  willing to go along with joe biden's  infrastructure deal now yeah we've seen  the devastating effects of hurricane ida  maybe the thing is like we see these  extreme weather events all the time